des lidd les convoyeurs se sont rejoints
dans la capitale qui je le disais
encadrés par un important dispositif de
sécurité
oui les coureurs de la liberté se sont
rejoints sur cette place à
sainte-catherine encadrés par un
dispositif de sécurité assez conséquents
qui bloque mais désormais elles aient
accès à tout s'est passé très vite les
convoyeurs sont arrivés sur cette place
ont scandé à plusieurs reprises le mot
liberté pour dénoncer les restrictions
sanitaires qui sont mises en place par
les gouvernements européens depuis
maintenant plus de deux ans et depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire il ya eu
quelques échauffourées entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants mais ça s'est
vite estompé et puis par la suite ils
ont continué à manifester pour dénoncer
vous lisez ces restrictions les
convoyeurs de la liberté ont fait de
bruxelles un objectif final pour l'heure
pour ce mouvement pour donner une
ampleur européenne a à ce mouvement et à
dénoncer tous les comportements des
gouvernements européens
la plupart d'entre eux dénoncé des
mesures liberticides
les lalala bruxelles avait pourtant
anticipé en prévoyant d'importants
dispositifs de de sécurité plutôt
conséquent mettant des camions et des
cars un peu partout dispatchés dans la
ville des canaux arrow également mais
malgré ça et bien les convoyeurs de la
liberté en rond ont réussi à force de
persuasion et de détermination à se
rendre ici un pour
réaliser cette manifestation je vous
propose d'écouter sara1 bertrand
coordinatrice de du convoi de la liberté
s'habille en liberté pour venir ici pour
défendre nos droits le droit à
l'information le droit de la santé à
choisir le traitement qui nous est
donnée pas une obligation qui est
discriminante mais en europe on est
censé être en démocratie
d'accord on est censé vivre libre et là
on est victime de lois liberticides et
du tout sinon on est là c'est clairement
on est des citoyens qui terrasse nous
étions inséré dans la société
nous accomplissions et nous
accomplissons encore nos devoirs et on
nous enlève nos droits donc on doit
continuer à se battre et clairement on
est des milliers et des milliers et s'il
faut continuer on continuera ça fait
sept mois en france qu'on est dans les
rues il pleut ménages y vante les gens
ils sont tous dans les rues ils arrivent
ils sont là vice vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure on se connaît tous on une
communauté tellement énorme c'est la
plus grande erreur qu'ils ont fait c'est
politique vous avez fait grandir à vous
nous avez réuni et aujourd'hui on est
éveillé on est déserte sur une
intelligence collective qui allons le
diffuser aux autres îles faisant de plus
en plus au fur et à mesure des mois
et c'est avec la pluie a quelque peu
éparpillé les manifestants sur cette
place sainte-catherine désormais un peu
dispatchés dans la ville le prochain
objectif c'est la commission européenne
à l'objectif principal 1 2 c'est un
convoyeur de la liberté évidemment
interpellé sept ces institutions
européennes afin de dénoncer le
comportement des gouvernements européens
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
il devra donc se rassembler a dit haye
d'ici peu tous là bas et puis plusieurs
autres convois sont partis eux vers
strasbourg vers le parlement européen où
la est là après fêtes josiane chevalier
était très strict à vis à vis de ce
mouvement elle a pris un arrêté
considérant qu'il était interdit de
manifester à strasbourg pour maintenir
l'ordre s'est montré très inflexible
vis-à-vis de ce mouvement en déclarant
qu'elle ne tolérerait aucun blocage de
la ville mais plusieurs convois ont pris
la direction de strasbourg entre
strasbourg et bruxelles en tout cas vous
l'aurez compris c'est est d'interpeller
16 institutions européennes pour les
convoyeurs de la liberté qui vont
poursuivre ce mouvement qui vont
poursuivre ce combat jusqu'au bout en
tout cas vous avez pu l'entendre la
détermination est toujours là pour à ces
convoyeurs de la liberté merci à vous
n'avez qu'à les faire pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de bruxelles